The Romans invented concrete over two thousands
years ago and built roads which are still
around today.
They used arches and domes to create monumental
buildings with big airy interiors that looked
truly Olympian—also still around.
And they moved thousands of tons of water
using aqueducts to keep a bustling population
un-thirsty.
These old buildings?
Also still around!
But did the Romans come up with ideas
about physics?
Like why arches support weight differently
than right-angled structures?
Did they ask proto-chemistry questions—that
is, “what is stuff?”—such as which tiny
things make up a good concrete?
Nope.
Let’s look at what knowledge the Romans
made in order to set up a debate that, spoiler
alert, is still going on: do you understand
something when you can explain why it’s
true, in the abstract?
Or do you understand something when you can
do things with it, even if you can’t explain why?
[Intro Music Plays]
The Romans inherited much of their knowledge from the Greeks.
From 323 to 31 BCE, the geometry, physics,
astronomy, and other disciplines developed
by the Presocratics, Plato, and Aristotle
spread throughout the Hellenistic world.
This “world” combined the parts of Asia,
Africa, and Europe influenced by Greek thought
due in large part to Alexander’s brief supervillain
rampage.
In Alexandria, Egypt—the biggest of the
seventy cities that Alexander named after
himself—the kings paid for the Museum, or
“house of the muses.”
This wasn’t a museum in the modern sense
of the word but more like a research university.
In Pergamon, in what is now Turkey, the kings
paid for the Library, which was—wait for
it—a really big collection of books.
These institutions lasted for centuries, drawing
visitors from far and wide.
Alas, over the same period of time that these
Greeks were supporting research, a tribe from
central Italy called the Romans went on a
new supervillain rampage… that also lasted
for centuries.
The Romans would continue to spread classical
Greek thought: we even call their culture
“Greco-Roman.”
But natural philosophy during Greco-Roman
times didn’t advance much.
Today, we remember the Romans for their engineering—or
ability to improve some real-world system—not
their deep thoughts about why the world is
the way it is.
Roman engineering built on Greek engineering.
Making knowledge is political, and most politicians
really want the same thing: bigger catapults
and lots of ships.
So Greco-Roman leaders did what heads of state
everywhere have always done: they paid smart
people to make bigger weapons.
In the ancient Mediterranean, the job of building
warmachines was called architecton, or architect.
Most of these “architects” were anonymous
and didn’t write down theories.
But, a few of them did.
The most famous architecton, Archimedes of
Syracuse, fought for the Greeks against the
Romans.
Archimedes is famous today as a mathematician:
he worked out many geometrical proofs
including the area of a circle, and pioneered
infinitesimals and exponents.
Archimedes also invented a lot of useful contraptions,
including the water screw and compound pulley.
The water screw pumps water by turning a screw
inside a pipe.
This was immediately useful in irrigation.
And a mechanical way to move water uphill
is just plain cool!
Archimedes also designed various warmachines
to kill the Romans who were trying to take
over his hometown.
He was so impressive that the Roman general
ordered his troops to capture, not kill, him.
But one soldier particularly low on chill
got frustrated when Archimedes wouldn’t
stop working on a mathematical proof.
In a sense, Archimedes kept it so real that
he got himself and, symbolically, an era of
Greek science killed.
Archimedes was interested in some of the natural
philosophy that explained his machines, but
for most other thinkers of his time, astronomy,
physics, and math were important for abstract,
quasi-religious reasons.
Making weapons was a matter of political power.
The heavens from which rain fell were perfect
and abstract.
Shipbuilding was an art, something learned
from practice.
It was not a matter of understanding hydrodynamics,
or the chemical properties of wood that make
it bendy and floaty.
Aristotle came up with a handy division between
these types of knowledge that we still use today.
He classified knowledge as either “useful”
or “theoretical.”
Useful knowledge was called technē, which
is where we get “technology.”
“Technology” has until recently, in historical
terms, been connected to the idea of “art”—meaning
something you learn by doing, and can see
in the real world.
Theoretical knowledge, on the other hand,
was epistēmē—the root of our word epistemology,
the study of knowledge.
Epistēmē is the sort of knowledge we most
associate with “science.”
Science is abstract, represented by formulas.
When historians of science talk about the
possibilities of what we can know, they use
the word “epistemic.”
One of the most influential thinkers working
on epistemic questions during the Greco-Roman
period was Claudius Ptolemy, a Greek or Greek-speaking
southern Egyptian living in Roman-held Alexandria.
In addition to optics and the science of music,
Ptolemy took up Plato’s old problem of how
to fit the observed data about how the planets
move to the theory of a cosmos made of perfect
circles with earth at its center.
He got really, really into this, mixing together
three kinds of solutions in order to make
the math work: epicycles, for example, were
the tiny circles that the planets moved along…
around bigger circles.
Ptolemy’s version of the cosmos, a mathematically
neater version of Aristotle’s and Plato’s,
became the basis of the understanding of the
universe across much of the medieval Christian
and Islamic world.
His great astronomical work, the Mathematical
Syntaxis, was renamed by Arabic scholars as
the Almagest, or The Greatest.
Fun fact: the Almagest may have been edited
by one of the first recorded female natural
philosophers, Hypatia of Alexandria.
So we’re on episode six of History of Science and, yes,
this is the first mention of a woman...
Ptolemy was also pretty much the authority
on earthly geography in the Greco-Roman world.
His book on the subject, called Geography,
discusses the data he uses and why.
It provided a resource for other scholars
to use in more accurately picturing and drawing
the world, for centuries.
Oh, and none of these thinkers thought that
the earth was flat.
Flat earth theory may have more proponents
today than it did in Greco-Roman times.
As Ptolemy shows, epistemic work was important
to a few Greco-Romans.
But what they’re really remembered for is
their technē, their engineering.
For example, people had been mixing together
water and rocks to make cement for generations.
But by 150 BCE, the Romans began mixing volcanic
ash, rocks, water, and lime to make Roman
concrete, or opus caementitium, which is one
of those technologies that the smarty-pants like
to call "a big freakin' deal.”
This new stuff was super durable and could
be poured into weird shapes like domes.
The Pantheon or Really Big Temple in Rome
is capped by a 143-foot diameter dome of concrete
that has stood for almost two thousand years.
But the Romans found out that arches support
more weight than straight joints.
This matters when you’re trying to move
something really heavy, like water.
Thus the Romans were able to move water long
distances using arch-y aqueducts.
This in turn allowed Roman cities to grow
in population, mines to run, and dry lands
to be irrigated.
The Romans changed their lands in other ways,
too: they drained the marshes of their home
city using an innovative sewer system called
the Cloaca Maxima, which literally means “Biggest
Sewer.”
Great name, my dudes.
The politician and civil engineer Sextus Julius
Frontinus wrote a landmark, comprehensive,
two-volume report on the design for the aqueducts
and sewers of Rome… which luckily a Renaissance
scholar found a copy of, just as the city
recovered from a roughly one thousand year
downturn in population.
Yes, that’s right: Roman infrastructural
engineering lasted through a millennium of
neglect and still worked!
But as great as gigantic open rooms, fresh
drinking water, and big-big sewers are, the
most important feat of Roman engineering may
have been their highways.
We hear a lot about “infrastructure” today.
And states have always made roads to foster
trade and move troops.
But Roman road builders took the art of logistics
to another level.
Show us what a big deal this was, Thought
Bubble!
Consider the Appian Way: running from Rome
southeast through the “heel” of Italy,
it connected several not very urbanized regions
of the peninsula.
Its first leg was built in 312 BCE—before
Roman concrete was perfected...
...using cement over layers of fitted stones
and gravel.
Drainage ditches lined its sides, and the
road was cambered to allow water to drain
off.
The Appian Way allowed Roman troops to efficiently
crush their enemies.
It was expanded over the centuries.
And the Appian Way is still around!
The cement has eroded away, but you can still
see many long, very straight sections.
It’s lined by trees, marked by monuments,
and haunted by history.
And the Appian Way is only one of several
well-preserved, two-thousand-year-old Roman
roads crisscrossing Africa, Asia, and Europe.
Metaphorically, all of these roads led to
Rome.
Her citizens paid taxes toward many large-scale
public works such as highways.
Perhaps the most important technology the
Romans optimized was the state itself: they
developed a complicated legal system, a well-supplied
army, public food assistance, and massive
public games.
One site of these games was the Flavian Amphitheater,
AKA the Colosseum.
It had a retractable roof that was staffed
by sailors who used complicated rigging to
move the canvas coverings around, and it was
sometimes flooded to allow for naval war games.
How many engineers today know how to properly
rig a giant sun-sail?
Or safely flood a public venue—without using
plastic?
Thanks, Thought Bubble, but these public works
were intended for Romans, not their property…
Before the industrial revolution, public works
such as aqueducts, sewers, and roads required
quarrying lots of materials and lots and lots
of labor.
And “labor” meant slaves.
Some estimates hold that one in three people
in Roman Italy were enslaved.
These people were involved in knowledge creation,
if against their will, by building and maintaining
all those great roads and other structures.
Roman slavery was a little different than
plantation slavery in the American South.
Slaves could be highly educated.
Many physicians were even slaves.
They could buy their freedom and become voting
citizens.
But most remained chattel—meaning property.
In 73 BCE, the gladiator Spartacus famously
led a slave revolt in Italy.
The freed slaves fought the army for two years,
but they were eventually defeated.
The survivors of the rebellion were crucified
along the Appian Way, from Rome to Capua,
over a hundred miles to the south.
Brutal story, but worth telling in the context
of Roman engineering.
Because the technologies that engineers make
are, like the sciences, political—only as
good or as bad as the humans who use them.
Roman thinkers left behind written sources
including histories, plays, proto-novels,
poems, legal manuals, and religious texts.
But only a few Roman texts deal with natural
philosophy.
Frontius’s guide to aqueducts was one exception.
Another was the Architecture of Vitruvius.
He wrote about buildings, but also urban planning
and even the plan of the human body.
By linking the limbs of the human body to
mathematical principles, Vitruvius inspired
Da Vinci’s “Vitruvian man.”
Vitruvius’s Architecture sums up the concepts
about knowledge common to the Hellenistic
and Greco-Roman worlds: it’s a technical
manual also concerned with the beautiful harmonies
of form inherent to bodies as well as the
efficient management of cities—the “body
politic.”
Next time—we’ll meet mechanical wonders
and the wonder of public healthcare in the
Abbasid Caliphate’s great capital, Baghdad.
Crash Course History of Science is filmed
in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney studio in Missoula,
Montana and it’s made with the help of all
this nice people and our animation team is
Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like The Financial Diet, The Art
Assignment, and Healthcare Traige.
And, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.